Robert Spencer here for jihad watch a
program of the David Horowitz Freedom
Center and for the Center for security
policy with the truth about the cynical
and deceptive report on Islamophobia
recently issued by the Hamas linked
Council on american-islamic relations
care the new report was Kerr's response
to the Orlando massacre perpetrated by a
Muslim who declared his allegiance to
the Islamic state or Isis instead of
announcing a program to teach young
Muslims why they should reject the
understanding of Islam held by the
Islamic state al Qaeda and other jihad
groups care just doubled down on its
Islamophobia narrative the whole
Islamophobia Enterprise is designed to
intimidate people into thinking that
there's something wrong with opposing
Jihad terror and this new report is no
different a few seconds of thought would
expose the deceptiveness of it to anyone
but Hamas linked care is banking on the
fact that most people especially on the
left but not limited to it will not give
the report even that much thought but
will just take it at face value anxious
to avoid being stigmatized themselves
with the Islamic label for those who are
willing to consider the facts however
here are some of the problems with the
new report first is that according to an
NBC report on cares latest Islamophobia
salvo 33 Islamophobic groups had access
to 205 million dollars between 2008 and
2013 to spread fear and hatred of
Muslims now what the NBC report doesn't
tell you and certainly what care doesn't
tell you are these groups part of one
umbrella organization no are they
collaborators some are and some aren't
do they share funding no so 205 million
dollars if that figure is even accurate
and it probably isn't over six years
spread out among 33 different and quite
disparate organizations that actually
averages out to a bit over a million a
year per organization a figure that is
actually not a large operating budget
for a major organization and outlets
doubtless much smaller than the
operating budget of Hamas linked care
itself in any given year and for the
record my organization jihad watch has
never had anything close
to a million dollars in any given year
second these organizations are
supposedly dedicated to spreading fear
and hatred of Muslims now that's not my
objective and I would venture to say
that it is not the objective of any of
the other people or organizations
mentioned in Hamas linked cares report
cares entire premise is false that to
call attention to Jihad terror activity
and to call for effective lawful
responses to it is tantamount to
spreading fear and hatred of Muslims
Hamas linked care and its allies have
spread this big lie so insistently for
so many years that it has entered the
American mainstream but that doesn't
make it any more true than it was when
they first advanced it if care had ever
provided even one example of a foe of
jihad terror who was simultaneously not
an islamaphobe in their eyes this charge
might have more credibility but they
never have in reality as far as Hamas
linked care is concerned any opposition
to Jihad terror any opposition to it at
all is Islamophobic and spreading fear
and hatred of Muslims
now this Islamophobia report also claims
that attacks on mosques have increased
with 78 recorded incidents in 2015 what
they don't say is this have I or any of
the others mentioned in this report ever
called for attacks on mosques of course
not have any of the people who attacked
mosques ever invoked any of us to
explain why they did so no have Muslims
faked hate attacks on mosques YES on
many occasions
so which is more likely that any actual
attack on a mosque by a non-muslim
vigilante idiot was provoked by our
reporting about jihad terror or was it
more likely that it was provoked by
jihad terror itself against which the
mosques in the US have not acted in any
strong fashion Hamas linked care would
have you believe that this alleged cabal
of Islamophobic individuals and groups
is responsible for American suspicion
and distrust of Muslims when in reality
the people who are responsible for any
actual suspicion and distrust of Muslims
are people like Omar Mateen psy
rizwan farook tashfeen Malik Dzhokhar
tsarnaev Tamerlan tsarnaev Nidal Malik
Hasan and myriad other jihad terrorists
in an introduction to the report itself
Hamas linked cares Nihad Awad says this
the report makes a case that those who
value constitutional ideals like equal
protection freedom of worship or an
absence of religious tests for those
seeking public office no longer have the
luxury of just opposing the US
Islamophobia networks biased messaging
but I don't oppose equal protection
freedom of worship or an absence of
religious tests for those seeking public
office and once again adventure to say
that none of the others mentioned in the
report do either this is a straw man
designed to demonize opponents of jihad
terror an opposition to jihad terror in
general in reality we're just trying to
do all we can via legal means to stop
jihad activity in the US but Hamas
linked care cannot and will not
acknowledge that because to do so would
reveal its own actual agenda so it has
to mischaracterize our aims the report
also says Islamophobia is a contrived
fear or prejudice fomented by the
existing Eurocentric and orientalist
global power structure it is directed at
a perceived or real muslim threat
through the maintenance and extension of
existing disparities in economic
political social and cultural relations
while rationalizing the necessity to
deploy violence as a tool to achieve
civilizational rehab of the target
communities muslim or otherwise now if
you cut through all this pseudo academic
gobbledygook you will see that what Kerr
is saying is that Islamophobia as a
contrived fear or prejudice is fomented
in response to a real muslim threat so
hamas linked care admits that there is a
real muslim threat but claims that the
Islamophobic individuals and groups in
its report have a wrong response to it
and indeed are representative of the
existing Eurocentric and orientalist
global power structure now the idea that
the global power structure today is
anything but fully in line with hamas
linked cares point of view today is
wildly absurd
but even aside from that nowhere does
care bother to explain what a proper
response would be to this acknowledged
real Muslim threat apparently it would
be nothing more or less than to
surrender to it since this Islamophobia
report is designed to defame and
discredit those who are standing against
it thereby clearing the field so that
the jihad can advance unimpeded and
unopposed
I'm Robert Spencer